F
THEIR CHOICE WHILE SUPPLIES
LAST.
NOW THIS.
HALL AND OATS CASH.
COMES TO RELATIONSHIP TOP
BILLING IS QUITE IMPORTANT.
GLAD THE WHITE HOUSE HAS GOT IT
DOWN.
>> A HARRIS ADMINISTRATION
TOGETHER WITH JOE BIDEN AS THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES.
>> HARRIS-BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
IS GOING TO RELAUNCH THAT
EFFORT.
>> PRESIDENT-ELECT HARRIS TOOK
HERS TODAY FOR THE SAME REASON.
>> WHEN PRESIDENT HARRIS AND I
TOOK A VIRTUAL TOUR OF A
VACCINATION CENTER OF ARIZONA.
>> Brian: A LITTLE COP FUSING.
NOW A LEAKED MEMO INDICATES
WHITE HOUSE COMMUNICATION
STAFFERS SHUT REPORTEDLY REFER
TO JOE AND KAMALA AS BIDEN
HARRIS ADMINISTRATION IN
OFFICIAL PUBLIC COMMUNICATIONS
INSTEAD OF BIDEN ADMINISTRATION.
AS BEEN DONE IN PREVIOUS WHITE
HOUSES FOX NEWS HAS REQUESTED
COMMENT FROM THE WHITE HOUSE
ABOUT THE CHANGE HAVE NOT HEARD
BACK.
JOINING US NOW IS SOMEONE WHO
SPENT TIME AT THE WHITE HOUSE
GEORGE W. BUSH'S WHITE HOUSE WHO
HAD A RUNNING MATE NAMED DICK
CHENEY BUT HE WAS NOT ON ALL THE
LETTERHEAD.
ARI FLEISCHER JOINS US.
ARI THERE IS 15 EXECUTIVE
DEPARTMENTS.
IT'S ALL SWITCHED NOW TO
BIDEN-HARRIS.
DO YOU READ ANYTHING INTO THIS?
>> WELL, WALTER CRONKITE, LET ME
TELL YOU MY TAKE ON THIS IS
EITHER ONE OF TWO THINGS, EITHER
JOE BIDEN IS BEING INCREDIBLY
GRACIOUS.
>> Brian: YEP.
>> JUST WANTS TO EXTEND THE
RUBRIC OF THE ADMINISTRATION TO
HIS VICE PRESIDENT OR IT'S A
REAL SIGN AND IT COULD BE BOTH
THAT JOE BIDEN IS DEFINITELY A
ONE-TERM PRESIDENT AT THE AGE OF
82 HE HAS NO INTENTION OF
RUNNING FOR RE-ELECTION AND HE
IS PAVING THE WAY NOW FOR HIS
PREFERRED CANDIDATE TO SUCCEED
HIM KAMALA HARRIS.
I STRONGLY SUSPECT IT'S THE
LATTER, MUCH MORE THAN THE
FORMER.
>> Brian: RIGHT.
NOW, SOMETHING ELSE THAT'S GOING
ON AND MIGHT BE BECAUSE THE
FORMER SENATOR, FORMER ATTORNEY
GENERAL IS NEW TO THE JOB.
BUT, AS YOU KNOW, THE MILITARY
IS ESCORTING OFF MILITARY PLANES
SHE SEEMS NOT TO BE SALUTING THE
MARINES, THE ARMY, WHOEVER IS
THE MILITARY OFFICER THERE WHO
IS GREETING HER.
IS THAT A PROBLEM?
>> YOU KNOW, I THINK IT'S A
MISTAKE BY HER.
I'M NOT GOING TO THROAT BOOK AT
HER ON THIS.
YOU KNOW, I JUST THINK IT'S ONE
OF THESE THINGS WHERE IF YOU
RESPECT THE MILITARY, IF YOU ARE
AWARE OF WHO THEY ARE, THEIR
SERVICE TO THE COUNTRY, IT'S
JUST KIND OF THE THING YOU
INTRINSICALLY AUTOMATICALLY DO
WHEN SOMEONE SALUTES YOU, YOU
SALUTE BACK.
I WILL SAY RONALD REAGAN STARTED
THAT TRADITION.
RONALD REAGAN WAS A VETERAN.
HE WAS FAMILIAR WITH BEING
SALUTED AT AND SALUTING BACK.
SHE'S NOT.
AND INTERESTINGLY, BRIAN, THE
VICE PRESIDENT IS NOT IN THE
MILITARY CHAIN OF COMMAND.
SO, YOU KNOW, WHEN SOMEBODY
SALUTES THE PRESIDENT, THAT'S
THE CHAIN OF COMMAND, EVEN
THOUGH HE IS NOT IN THE UNIFORM.
>> Brian: GOT CHANCHTS VICE
PRESIDENT IS NOT IN THE UNIFORM
AND NOT IN THE MILITARY OF
COMMAND IT'S THE PRESIDENT AND
THE SECRETARY OF DEFENSE AND
DOWN FROM THERE.
BUT, STILL, THE POINT REMAINS
THE SAME.
IT'S JUST GOOD MANNERS.
YOU SHOULD RESPECT THE MILITARY
WHEN THEY SALUTE, SALUTE BACK.
>> Brian: I'M ALSO RESPECTING
THE FACT THAT THERE IS A MEASURE
MOVING THROUGH THE HOUSE AND
INTO THE SENATE NOW H ARE 1
THAT'S GOING TO FEDERALIZE
ELECTIONS.
WE CAN GET THAT DETAIL THAT WILL
CHANGE ELECTIONS.
ELECTION DAY LIKE WE HAVE NEVER
HAD BEFORE, MORE LIKE ELECTION
MONTH.
AS HR 1 TRY POSITION GIVE THE
VOTING TO MORE AND MORE PEOPLE,
ACCORDING TO THE DEMOCRATS.
ISN'T IT IRONIC THEY ARE TRYING
TO TAKE A HOUSE SEAT AWAY IN
IOWA AND EVEN TWO DEMOCRATS
THINK THIS IS OUT OF BOUNDS.
IRONIC?
>> WHAT'S HAPPENING IN IOWA IS
AN ABSOLUTE POWER GRAB.
AND EVERYBODY SHOULD BE ALARMED
ABOUT WHAT NANCY PELOSI IS
TRYING TO ENGINEER.
LOOK, THIS IS NOTHING AT ALL
LIKE WHAT HAPPENED ON
JANUARY 6TH.
ON JANUARY 6TH, SOME
REPUBLICANS, NOT ALL, SOME
REPUBLICANS VOTED TO DISALLOW
THE ELECTION OF BIDEN, IT WOULD
NOT HAVE RESULTED IN PUTTING IN
DONALD TRUMP.
IT JUST WOULD HAVE SOWED
CONFUSION.
HERE THIS IS INTERNAL COUP.
WHAT THEY ARE TRYING TO DO IS
THROW OUT THE INCUMBENT
REPUBLICAN AND REPLACE HER WITH
A DIFFERENT DEMOCRAT.
THAT IS A TOTAL DIFFERENCE FROM
JANUARY 6TH.
AND IT'S AN ABUSE OF POWER.
IF THE HOUSE GOES THROUGH WITH
THIS, I THINK THERE IS GOING TO
BE HELL TO PAY.
THERE WILL BE SUCH A REBELLION
GOING ON IN THE HOUSE.
IF I'M KEVIN McCARTHY WHOEVER
WINS BYYOU DO NOT WANT TO GO DOT
ROAD.
>> Brian: MARIANNETTE
MILLER-MEEKS WON THE ELECTION
SHE GOT SWORN IN AND SITTING.
RITA HART WANTS AN ELECTION.
SHE DIDN'T GO IT IOWA.
SHE IS GOING TO FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT TO GET HER SEAT BACK
AND EVEN DEMOCRATS ARE UPSET BY
IT.
I REMEMBER SOMETHING SIMILAR
HAPPENED IN THE 1980s WITH
NEWT GINGRICH WHEN HE WAS
MINORITY MEMBER AND HELPED HIM
BECOME SPEAKER OF THE HOUSE.
ARI, IT'S JUST UNBELIEVABLE
WHAT'S HAPPENING NOW.
DO YOU EXPECT HR 1 TO ACTUALLY
GET GREEN LIGHTED IN A SIMPLE
MAJORITY?
>> YOU KNOW, I CAN'T SEE IT
PASSING IN THE SENATE.
IT'S PUBLIC FINANCING IN
CAMPAIGNS WHICH TAXPAYERS HAVE
ALWAYS OBJECTED TO.
WHY SHOULD MY MONEY GO TO PAY
FOR NANCY PELOSI?
WHY SHOULD DEMOCRAT MONEY GO TO
PAY FOR MARJORIE TAYLOR GREEN?
I DON'T THINK IT WILL PASS THE
SENATE.
>> Brian: